Speaker 1: . Hey, I want to talk about
something called the Havana Syndrome. This
is super interesting and also pretty scary. I I
actually had not really read much about this until
yesterday. I'll tell you what the news is and
then I'm going to talk to you about what Havana
syndrome is. So article from CNN. Possible Havana
Syndrome incident delayed Kamala Harris flight
to Vietnam. Look at this. Vice President Kamala
Harris departure for Vietnam was delayed by
several hours Tuesday afternoon after her office
was informed by the U.S. embassy in Hanoi,
Vietnam, of a, quote, report of a recent possible
anomalous or anomalous, both acceptable health
incident. That term is the way that the
government usually refers to the mysterious
Havana syndrome that has sickened hundreds
of U.S. officials over the past few years,
Rachel Chen, a spokeswoman for the U.S. embassy
in Hanoi, said earlier this evening the vice
president's traveling delegation was delayed from
departing Singapore because the vice president's
office was made aware of a report of a recent
possible anomalous health incident in Hanoi.
After a careful assessment, the decision was
made to continue with the vice president's trip.
Aboard Air Force Two, Harris's chief spokeswoman,
Simone Sanders, told traveling reporters
that Harris is, quote, Well, all is fine and
looking forward to meetings in Hanoi tomorrow.
This has nothing to do with the vice president's
health. Harris eventually took off from Singapore
as a pile of our air base after a more than three
hour delay. So what is this Havana syndrome? This
is absolutely wild. Havana syndrome is a set
of medical signs and symptoms reported by U.S.
and Canadian embassy staff in Cuba dating back to
late 2016, as well as subsequently in some other
countries, including the US, Austria and Germany.
In 2017, Donald Trump accused Cuba of perpetrating
unspecified attacks, causing these symptoms. The
U.S. reduced staff at their embassy to a minimum
response. In twenty eighteen, U.S. diplomats in
China reported problems similar to those reported
in Cuba, as did undercover CIA agents working in
other countries with partner agencies to counter
Russian covert operations. Subsequent studies of
the effect the diplomats in Cuba, published in the
journal JAMA in twenty eighteen, found evidence
that the diplomats experienced some form of brain
injury but did not determine the cause of the
injuries. While there is no expert consensus on
the cause of the symptoms, a coauthor of the JAMA
study considered microwave weapons to be a main
suspect of the phenomenon, U.S. National Academy
of Sciences Engineering and Medicine Expert
Committee concluded in December of 2020 that
microwave energy specifically directly pulsed
RF energy quote appears to be the most plausible
mechanism in explaining these cases among those
that the committee considered, but that each
possible cause remains speculative. So understand
what the the speculation is. The idea here is
knowing where there are diplomats at embassies,
as one example, adversaries or other intelligence
or security agencies may be directing microwave
weapons at these embassies to
cause symptoms in individuals
in terms of the symptoms, they include hearing
loss, memory loss and nausea. Speculation centered
around a sonic weapon, with some researchers
pointing to infrasound as a possible cause.
This has led to the US expelling Cuban diplomats.
This has led to the U.S. State Department removing
non-essential staff from the embassy in Cuba.
Donald Trump said he believes Cuba is responsible.
This goes well beyond Cuba, actually, in reality.
And if you look at theories regarding cause,
there is microwave's, as one previously proposed,
were ultrasound via inter modulation distortion,
cricket noises and exposure to neurotoxic
pesticides, pesticides or infectious agents
being looked at, and then also the possibility of
a psychogenic origin. Some individuals speculate
without evidence that the symptoms represent
episodes of mass hysteria. That appears to not
be the case. And with something like this, we've
got to be careful to separate, speculative and
completely unfounded possible causes from those
that are actually showing up in the medical
literature. So what is is this a form of is this a
form of terrorism? Is this a is this an action of
war or are these intelligence operations? It's
absolutely bizarre. I had heard nothing about
this. I don't even remember the Trump stuff
with Cuba in twenty in twenty eighteen. But
an absolutely incredible situation. And
Havana syndrome is what it is. It is called
what should this be considered if indeed it is as
reported. And what should be the reaction of the
United States? I don't know. I just learned about
this stuff in the last 12 hours. I'd be curious to
hear from you. You can find me on Twitter at David
Pakman. We will take a quick break. And after the
break, we're going to explore a new medical ethics
study that asks the question when it comes to
covid, would it be fair to treat vaccinated
patients first? Would it be fair to take
vaccination into consideration in terms of triage?
We'll talk about that right after this short break